so when you compare bitcoin fiat
currency and gold you can cut it by a
bunch of different perspectives and so
what we have here is we have a chart
that compares these three assets bitcoin
gold and fiat according to the traits of
money and what you find here is that if
you look by verifiability fungibility
portability durability divisibility
scarce established history censorship
resistance unforgettable unforgeable
costliness open programmable and
decentralized when you add all those up
bitcoin is superior to gold and to fiat
especially as a store of value and so
let's take these one by one verifiable
you can actually audit and verify
bitcoin gold we kind of sort of know how
much there is we kind of sort of know
how much is coming out of the ground
every year and same with fiat is we kind
of sort of know what the balance sheets
are and we kind of sort of know how much
is in existence but if i asked you right
now explain to me how much dollars or
other fiat currency in the world were
created today you don't know you have no
clue also with gold if i say tell me
right this second how much gold was
actually pulled out of the ground today
you don't know if you guys got any
bitcoin or credited to it's 900
how do i know i can prove it to you on a
blockchain i can actually show it to you
900 bitcoin today why do i know that
because it's on a transparent ledger so
it's much more verifiable fungible they
all have about the same fungibility you
don't need to have the same dollar you
don't need to have the same bitcoins as
long as you have one bitcoin equals one
bitcoin you can spend it portable if you
think about fiat or you think about
bitcoin both exist in some sort of
electronic or digital form there is very
very high portability the ability to
move it around the world very quickly
now gold obviously sucks for this it's
hard it's a physical analog asset and so
it's very difficult to move gold around
the world now durability of course when
you look at this the durability of the
asset i would disagree with this
analysis that says that bitcoin is only
moderately durable i think that part of
that durability ultimately comes from
the
lack of established history but also a
lot of people who don't realize that the
digital version of the asset makes it
more durable than the analog version
historically people have thought of the
analog version as being the most durable
and then obviously fiat fiat sucks
purchasing power keeps getting decreased
and it's done uh divisibility obviously
bitcoin is much more divisible than gold
but fiat is also more divisible than
gold as well we can get 100 pennies out
of a dollar and with bitcoin we have 100
million satoshis for every one bitcoin
and so ultimately the divisibility
bitcoin is number one fiat is number two
and then gold obviously is the worst one
and the hardest scarce
fiat there's no scarcity at all it's
abundant there's so much fiat floating
around in this world and so much more
coming that you literally could walk
down the street and people leave it
laying on the street there's literally
countries in this uh in this world where
they take the money and they create art
with it it's so abundant and so gold
obviously has low abundance uh or high
scarcity uh or moderate scarcity uh but
compared to bitcoin bitcoin is the most
scarce it's the only one that actually
has a finite supply to it and therefore
it is the most scarce asset that you
could own out of these three established
history fiat and bitcoin here's a key
piece of this gold's been around for you
know thousands and thousands of years
fiat's been around for about 50
bitcoin's been around for about 12. but
ultimately in the grand scheme of
thousands and thousands of years fiat
and bitcoin both have very little
established history they both have been
around for a minuscule amount of time
compared to gold and that thousands of
years track records so it's important to
kind of think about fiat and bitcoin are
basically the same in the grand scheme
of things censorship resistance fiat
there's no censorship resistance gold
kinda if you have it in physical form
but obviously bitcoin complete
censorship resistance a peer-to-peer
network and of course it is superior in
that way costliness pretty
self-explanatory programmable fiat not
programmable at all gold doesn't even
know how to be used by a computer
bitcoin is a digitally native asset and
therefore the programmability of it is
superior in a major major way and
obviously decentralized fiat there is no
decentralization it's completely
centralized in a hierarchical structure
it's literally 12 people at the fomc
that decide what is the monetary policy
for billions of people around the world
that use u.s dollars and we have no clue
how or why they make the decisions they
make they simply go into a room in their
suits and ties with the cologne on while
they drink their sprites and smoke
cigars and they come out and they tell
us here's what our interest rate policy
decisions are going to be good luck
gold moderate decentralization why
because it is buried all over the ground
but it ultimately gets financialized and
centralized it's held in vaults and
banks and also by the mining companies
themselves bitcoin though bitcoin is the
most decentralized asset in the world
it's the strongest computing network and
that peer-to-peer network nobody can
shut it down nobody can actually
successfully attack it and so when you
add up all of these things bitcoin
spirit of gold and fiat across many
different aspects and as the digital
native generation grows up i personally
believe that people are going to
continue to adopt bitcoin in a material
way that will make look gold and fiat
foolish